in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some VR expert with their
disk performance does this VR headset
make my performance look awesome stay
tuned to find out VR ignition is a
company specializing in the processing
of content for VR and AR applications
their product can scale to handle
massive point clouds across thousands of
CPUs using the Google cloud platform and
due to the nature of their algorithms
had a large need for local SSDs to
handle their out of court algorithms
however they were confused because they
weren't getting the type of read
performance they were expecting from
these high-performance
discs I'll spare you some of the
debugging details but it turned out that
the problem was with their disk
interface see for local SSDs there's two
primary interfaces scuzzy and nvm II
scuzzy of course we've all seen for
years now and is the default for most
disk interfaces in our data centers and
via me however is the new kid on the
block designed with modern technologies
in mind to provide higher performance
now for example whereas scuzzy has one
cue for commands nvme is designed to
have up to 64,000 cues on moreover each
of those cues can in turn have up to
64,000 commands simultaneously now you
can switch what interface your machine
uses at creation time by passing along
the interface tag to the local SSD per
am and to show the performance
difference we can see the two
head-to-head we clearly see that nvme
has an advantage with respect to read
performance and a slight advantage over
write performance but here's the catch
in order to use nvm II you have to have
a disk image that supports it and this
was the thing that was hurting VR
ignition firstly they weren't setting
the flag and secondly they weren't using
a custom image for their builds that
didn't have nvme support thankfully
after a decent amount of technical
discussion they were able to move to a
public image that was already optimized
for nvme which let them get the big
boost in performance if you'd like to
know more about this topic check out the
article linked in the description below
and don't forget to check out the rest
of the cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts
you